it started as a legend one of the
greatest of all thousand years we've
kept it hidden
to protect her what is destined to
arrive Optimus Prime we destroy your
home the credentials
I to me
[Music]
your daughter what would you say to her
brush your teeth work hard stay with
many boy in a band especially a drummer
these are trouble times without leaders
chaos reigns
two worlds colliding
you're all that stand in its way now the
greatest mission of them all we turn the
type of human history
Rock them can't do it
[Applause]
the imminent destruction of everything
we know and love begins
I'm not leaving you
when all seems lost a few breaks
[Music]
okay everything the government
operations over
we're not giving up a prime okay
I'm safe
and then once like this
[Music]
or my world to live
yours must die
[Music]
you want to know don't you while they
keep coming here you well this dying
[Music]
week redemption and money makers I do
[Applause]
[Music]
it has been sent through the ages
without sacrifice there could be no
victory to species at war one flesh one
metal
[Music]
Optimus Prime has left us 100 million
current habits in the cosmos you want to
know don't you
hey why they keep coming here
[Music]
on a stake and I want to fight them
now two worlds colliding
now far as soon as over we're not giving
up okay
only one survives
oh my god
forgive me
[Music]
you
[Music]
you